uh
he had a run last year once he got put
in that starting rotation
where he was pitching as well as anybody
in baseball
and novice brings up christian
yellowstone a good pitch by braults
and how's the rock his first start of
the season hoping to build off
the way he finished the season last year
the old one is a strike runner goes
throw down to second
in time manny pina guns down
kevin newman for out number two what a
perfect throw from manny pena the rain
has fallen fast here at pnc park between
innings matt brown
groundskeeper saying all right we gotta
we gotta call this
and here comes the rain and this is a
real challenge
when it's raining heavily to get the
tarp
on the field i know from experience in
my minor league days
1 42 the official time of the rain delay
moran you see that good start 4 for 11.
and moran sends one down the line and
right
and he's hovered again the redbeard is
hot
[Applause]
you know i think that's a replay of that
home run we just showed
st louis little slider down and in
in the strike zone though the down and
in corner of the strike zone
and he just dropped the head of the bat
to it hit it the same way
it's identical balls in a strike on
osuna
little jam shot flare that is going to
be
caught by hira got a chance at a double
play the throw to first in time
yeah well done kesten here going back
and realizing
that reynolds was too far off the bag
able to turn two
good job by casting hira
kind of a flare out in the short right
field and
he knew he knew that the runner was off
the bag a little bit too far
spins around and makes good the right
fielder coming in could throw you out at
second anyways polanco making his season
debut
sprays one to left coming on yelich long
run sliding and he makes the catch
in foul ground christian yelich makes
the third out of the inning
the first time in a long time for chad
cool he's going to get an
opportunity to pitch on a big league
mount for the first time in more than
two
years
nice curve back to back nice curves
two outs chad cool for the bucks with a
2-2 pitch swing and a miss he struck him
out
another slider a couple of k's two men
left three and a half played from pnc
park pirates one brewers nothing
brewers have just one hit with runners
on base tonight
one for 12. now kane with runners at the
corner
and lorenzo in the left field of base
head
in the score is garcia
kane delivers the tying run
lorenzo's second rbi of the season
all tied at one piece of hitting by
lorenzo kane picking on a fastball up in
the strike zone not messing around
going up there swinging right down the
middle a little bit up but able to
hit it hard in the left colin moran his
home run give the pirates a one-nothing
lead
moran out to right oh let's watch this
one go
goodbye splashdown
our first home run in the allegheny
for colin moran
yeah we were talking about well he'd
make double figures in home runs
this season he might do it his home
stand
that was an absolute blast there so now
they're loaded for dyson here's the
pitch
tyson lines it off the tip of the glove
of
the second baseman herrera scores one
will score a couple
gerard dyson his first hit as a bucko
gives the pirates a 4-1 lead in the
seventh
scoring reynolds and heredia
boy that's a big hit right there does a
nice job of laying off a couple of
breaking balls to go
3-2 a two-run two-out base is loaded
single by dyson
and here comes another
stallings making his way to third pays
off five to one pirates
brewers would love to put another one on
them right here oh look out that got him
it hit him casting hira hit by a pitch
just grazed him
and the brewers will get a run in and
we'll get yellets to the plate as the
go-ahead run now
no kidding big 5-2 pirates
in the ninth brewers making some noise
so here's yelich
facing feliz he's one for five against
him lifetime
2-0 pitch swung on ground ball right
side bell has it he's going to go to the
bag a runs going to come
in to make it five to three to run
scoring ground out for christian yelich
ryan braun in the box one swing of the
bat the brewers could take the lead here
in pittsburgh in the ninth
and that is way inside i don't know how
it missed him right you can see that
slider
and not sure how ryan got out of the way
five three
two outs ninth inning here's a one two
and braun rips one down the left field
line
this is gonna score two and the brewers
have tied it in the ninth as brawn
rolls into second with a double wow how
about that
a one-two pitch a slider and ryan able
to tuck it inside the third base bag
and tie her up how about that a
four-run ninth inning for the brew crew
there it is
gonna see extra innings under the new
rules for the first time
strike three call
[Applause]
slow roller out to short sogard makes
the play
and david phelps holds serve brock holt
will be the base runner to start this
11th inning is going to be eric sogard
with brockhold at second base nebraska's
deals
and into left field that is down a base
hit
on his way home is brock holt sogard on
his way to second
and he's in there with a belly flop
double
a nice piece of hitting by eric sogar i
know you try and pull that baseball
a little ground ball to second although
you wouldn't get the runner to third
base but you do that you drive him
in beautiful piece of hitting by eric
sogart
full count two outs and a swing and a
miss
phelps strikes out reynolds to end the
game
the brewers win tonight